I don't want to risk burning MY CONTACT BECAUSE I'M NOT WRITING
A JOURNALISTIC story on it. >> Here is the reality, no
one should talk about any of this. This is all really complicated.
No one is going to deal with the [__] is going on.
>> Dude, there's no way that he just said these words.
>> Is he saying something public?
A public disclosure? I mean like, kind >> Is saying something
public a public disclosure? Can this guy not process lying about
two people at the same time? Does he not have like the brain
power, the bandwidth for it anymore? I used to listen to this
guy talk and it made sense. And now it like never makes any
>> That's fine. That like if if that's your perspective,
that's okay. My standard for journalism is a bit higher. No,
no, this is your This is slop journalism you're describing. >> That's
the I freelance from the mainstream media. I can't I just wrote
a big piece for Vanity Fair and the Guardian last week. I can't
write for those organizations if I was accepting dark money.
>> Well, first of all, yes, you can. Of course you can.
You don't have to declare every single income source. Any Of
course you can. Yeah, of course you can. Hold on, let's see what
my favorite Justical Disborder has to say.
So, I don't think that Destiny is necessarily actually stating
that this is a dark money group. I think he's pretending to be
an idiot in order to use the same kind of in >> Here's
the reality. >> Do you notice he can't even like legitimately
engage with anything? He's got to always poison the well instantly.
My favorite This is what Let's see what my favorite Justical
Disborder has to say. This guy doesn't even post in the Discord.
This guy doesn't talk. What? What? Participates in like eight
other Discords way more than he participates in mine.
Substance is never in the Discord. Is he talking about Dan? He's
possibly talking about Dan. Dan does participate far more in
the Discord than Substance does. That's true. That is true. >> Disborder
has to say.
So, I don't think that Destiny is necessarily actually stating
that this is a dark money group. I think he's pretending to be
an idiot in order to use the same kind of in >> Here's
the reality, no one should talk about any of this. This is all
retardedly complicated. No one is going to deal with the [__]
is going on. Taylor definitely doesn't know what the [__]
is going on. I think I have a better handle than I think anybody
else in this conversation. If you're not willing to spend a lot
of time diving through this [__] it's not worth it.
Holy Holy AIDS. And so, I don't >> I don't think that that's
necessarily actually stating that this is a dark money group.
I think he's pretending to be an idiot in order to use the same
kind of insults that Taylor Lorenz and Hasan [__]
have used against other creators against Taylor Lorenz. >> So,
here he does the thing again where he just says, "Oh, I guess
nobody should talk about it." And I think I also have the best
He doesn't have the best command. Well, he got lectured on it
by Tom Foolery. He had no idea what he's talking about. And then
Tom Foolery came in and gave him his only talking point.
That's crazy that he's just like, "Nobody should talk about this.
It's way too complicated. It's AIDS." Like Bro, just do some
research. If you want to actually like dispute something from
the article, by the way, the article which is almost entirely
about transparency in funding. It's not saying you can't take
money from billionaires. It's not saying you can't take money
basically anywhere. It's It's literally saying, "It is best to
be transparent.
You should be transparent with the money you get. It's a problem
that people are taking money or giving money and not being transparent
about it." Nobody in my chat, nobody in my community has any
problem with Course beyond the fact that Course creators don't
disclose if they're getting paid.
If they disclose that they're getting paid, I've got no issue
with it at all. Doesn't bother me at all.
It's goofy, man. It's just It's so >> So, I I think all
that's If I had to guess, he's pretending to be an idiot. He
doesn't actually think it's dark money, but may maybe he'll come
out and be like, "Oh, no, no, no, it is dark money." Like I I
don't know. We'll see. >> Very [__] annoying
uh to to listen to her make a bunch of points that are untrue
again in their >> Oh, I love the clip chiming. I was watching
Tom's stream for a bit last night and then going back and forth.
The clip It's a clip
This is a clip Twitter account. Yeah, they're going to do clips.
What part of this Hold on. Clip chiming would mean that you're
cutting context out. What context is missing from this? What
part of this did Tom cut against in the rest of his stream?
He's going to touch on it. Okay, I got >> Because Tom thought
some things that weren't true. This is in the beginning part
of his stream, but I'm guessing they don't include the other
parts, huh? >> conversation and Destiny miss on all of
the things that are actually
What are those other parts? Is there Is he going to say what
any of that is?
What's the other part?
Like I don't doubt that Tom doesn't want to upset you. He understands
he like gets clout from you. He like likes you. You're friend,
right? I understand that he might, you know, try to soften this
a little bit later on or something. But what is actually cut
against?
I don't What is cut He's about to talk about how oh, Destiny
was wrong and didn't point out the major things Taylor got wrong.
That or that Destiny's like how he approached this. When did
he change
>> Because Tom thought some things that weren't true. This
is in the beginning part of his stream, but I'm guessing they
don't include the other part. >> What did Tom think that
wasn't true? >> conversation and Destiny miss on all of
the things that are actually untrue and keep pushing on the things
that are that he's wrong on. Like he's playing on the [__]
Like he is he is just wrong. Like does not qualify as dark money
under her definition, not under anybody's definition. It just
does not qualify as dark money. >> Oh, that's the best
part about this is it's totally disingenuous. They're like, "Oh,
under Taylor's standard." And then she's like, "That's not my
standard." And they're like, "Under Taylor's standard. Under
Taylor's standard, this is dark money." No, it's not. It's so
And so
there's a way you can critique somebody,
You can critique them by your standard
or I guess if there's like a a neutral like relatively
well-respected third party, you could critique by that
In this case, that doesn't exist. Or you could critique by their
standard. You could do an internal critique of their
But Destiny does neither cuz Destiny doesn't believe it's dark
money, right? Destiny wouldn't call this dark money. It's He
doesn't want to concede. That's why he says this is actually
really complicated and stupid we shouldn't talk about it. He
doesn't want to concede that by his standards not dark money.
He doesn't want to concede that by Taylor's standards it's not
dark money.
But it's not. So, why are we applying a standard that nobody
cares about, right? And you have to have like deeper conversations
here. It's just very goofy. I I He has such a huge ego that he
can't just admit he was wrong and walk away. He's to keep doubling
down again and again and again and again.
He tried to get out of it yesterday and then we called him out
and now he's doubling down again on like, "Well, actually it
is dark money though and she doesn't know exactly where it comes
It's very goofy. >> I think Destiny's it it would 100%
but the issue is that like Tom thought I actually was something
for me for a minute. So, like Omidyar Group that's not a thing.
That's not a real thing. There is no such thing as like the Omidyar
Group LLC or incorporated network or anything like that. It's
that's just like an umbrella term given for a whole bunch of
different companies that are part of >> that are all started
and funded entirely by Pierre Omidyar.
thing that like pri- >> that that they all get their their
initial funding. So, I think what happens is when one of their
things does really well or if like it becomes advantageous to
do so, they've spun out other investment firms. So, the LLC is
like an impact investing firm. They invest in stuff that they
think morally affects the world in a positive way, right? Like
based on their principles they will invest in things that they
think better the world. And sometimes one section of their fund
gets big and they spin it out into another fund. But that comes
from Pierre Omidyar they're managing Pierre Omidyar's money.
That new entity is still his money. It's still all his money
and they spin it out and manage it in a different place with
like a more focused goal. So, I think that's what's happened
with a couple of these different things that spin out of the
LLC.
Is they take some subset of assets and I think because maybe
they need more manpower, I don't know what it is. I don't know
why they do it. Maybe it's like promoting people, right? What
if you have like somebody who's a like a genius and you they're
going to go start their own company and so you say, "Oh, wait.
I'll actually make you an owner, a half owner of like this LLC
and we'll spin it out and you can manage the assets over there."
Right? There's a lot of different reasons you would do something
like that. But all of the Omidyar Network stuff, that's all just
all funded by him, it's all with him. >> Projects that
Pierre Omidyar or whatever has founded.
That was one of the misunderstandings. But we cleared that up
last night. Don't worry about it. >> I think Destiny's
getting confused or maybe maybe I'm wrong, but the guy Omidyar,
the guy with the last name Omidyar, he has donated like 40 million
dollars to the What is it called? The 1630 Fund? But I don't
think that the group that she is a part of like this incubator
program for journalists, it's like a journalist cohort. I think
that is directly funded by that Omidyar guy. >> It's not
though. YOU THERE'S NOT. THAT'S WHY THAT'S WHY YOU HAVE TO RELY
ON HER WORD FOR IT. THERE'S NO FORMS to look.
>> But he doesn't know that it's not. He just said something
that he knows is wrong. He's going to make the subtler point
of like, "Well, you can't prove
But I don't know why we're pretending we don't understand why
like non-transparent funding doesn't work. Like or or why people
are hesitant to support it. They want the transparency. They
want to see this cuz they want to know the motives of the people
giving the money. Destiny understands this when he talks about
how if you take dark money, then it's your reputation and he
doesn't feel like that's dark money anymore, right? That's why
he defends Coors. He understands it in that case. I don't know
why he pretends not to understand it in this case.
Right? He just pretends he doesn't understand it. But it's literally
the it's literally the Pierre Omidyar guy going, "Here's all
of my motives. Here's what I'm about. I'm giving money."
That's That's the thing you want with transparency. And it's
like technically he could have somebody else in there doing something.
But all situations where you try to come up with an idea of how
that would happen or why that would happen, they don't make sense.
So, the thing I've asked people repeatedly whenever this topic
comes up is could you give me a plausible situation, a situation
you think could actually be the case for why Pierre Omidyar would
run this fund he would run this trust and then that trust would
give to the LLC and the Omidyar Network like the the 501c3 and
the LLC and why he would constantly say this is all of my money
and why that would be a lie. Why would he be lying with that?
Any Any answer that's like, "Oh, well, actually he wants to hide
contributions from like a Let's say he's Iranian, right?" Pierre
Omidyar actually I I believe a Persian Iranian, okay? What if
he wanted to do advocacy on behalf of Iran? What if that's why
he supports progressive groups because they tend to be campus,
they tend to think America bad and so they support Iran, right?
What if he's getting money from Iran? It's like, "Okay, you could
do that, but then why would he ever
why would he ever take money from Iran and put it into these
things when he's already a billionaire? When you just put his
own money in and take money from Iran in some shell account somewhere
else. You'd never be able to track that
All of the reasons that like you could come up with, you would
never be able to fix them through seeing even transparently all
of his LLC's books. You'd never see any of it, right?
He's he's performing for his audience. He uh uh
he'll flail around in exaggeration, then it makes everyone
Sorry, you need to rewrite whatever that flail around in exaggeration,
then it makes everyone look crazy because they are so stupid
that his only reaction is, "Oh my god." repeats the point in
a loud voice. Yeah, I
I guess. I ask people this I just It's the sign that someone's
not cattle if they can try to come up with an answer, but most
people don't even try. They just apply the disingenuous standard
like the level of precision they require from Taylor.
And by the way, if any of these were their positions, that you
could they could say, "Well, actually my position is that that's
dark money." No, it's not. Or else, if this is your position,
then all of the Coral stuff, you think Coral needs to be shut
down, right? Cuz all of the Coral stuff is far more opaque than
anything Taylor does or Pierre Omidyar does.
So, you obviously think the Coral stuff is bad, but it's all
the Coral defenders who are trying to apply this disingenuous
third standard that doesn't apply to Taylor. It's not Taylor's
standard. It's not their standard. They just want to discredit
her. That is their only goal.
>> People are Also, Taylor is partially at fault here.
I can't tell if cuz she's stupid or being malicious. When people
say public disclosure,
We're playing a tricky thing here. Now, is me saying something
>> Dude, everything is about how she's Kelly Jean. It's
>> thing public
a public disclosure? I mean, like
I forgot about this. Hold on. Hold on. >> Hold on. >> We're
playing a tricky thing here. Now, is me saying something public
a public disclosure? I mean, like kind of, but >> Dude,
there's no way that he just said these words. Is saying something
public a public disclosure?
Uh yeah. Yeah. Obviously so, yeah. Yeah, it obviously is, yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, it is.
It's so crazy. It's It's actually
Yeah, I don't know. It's wild, man. >> That public disclosure
is a lot different than me publishing a tax form for public inspection,
okay? These are two very, very, very different things.
he's not asking for a tax form for public inspection. He's asking
for somebody's motives when they donate, right? Now, the thing
that you get with a 501c4 LLC combination is you don't get somebody's
name or motives.
Pierre Omidyar, to be transparent, even though his name wasn't
disclosed when he donated the $45 million to 1630, he came out
and said, "Actually, that's me." Did he produce? Everybody considered
that a public disclosure, by the way. Yeah, he gave $45 million
to this this
I don't believe I don't know if I don't think his name was in
any documents.
He technically could have been lying about that, but realistically,
it doesn't matter if he's lying about it. It It's literally the
idea that he would come out and say, "Hey, no, 45 million 45
million Semaphore." I'm not talking about the Omidyar Network
LLC thing. Pierre Omidyar himself gave $45 million to 60 to 1630
fund, and then he said, "I did that cuz he likes to be transparent
about his giving."
Here are my motives. I'm giving you all of this stuff, right?
I'm giving you all the information. And it's like technically,
if you could find out he was lying, that would be a big deal.
Right? But he has no reason to lie about these things.
There's just no logical reason. So, you're you're sort of contriving
this artificial scenario where this could possibly make sense
to try to point out somebody else's hypocrisy, but it's not their
standard. It's like an imagined hypocrisy. We've contrived a
completely unthinkable scenario to try to catch somebody else
in a hypocrisy that doesn't exist.
For what reason? Well, uh Taylor Lorenz likes the sun, I think.
Taylor Lorenz is working for the downfall of towards the downfall
of the
This is what we're trying to do. And so,
it's like transparent, and I I talked to like somebody about
this if if anybody wants to come and argue this, I feel like
it's very easy to argue.
It's not confusing what's going on here.
And he's got I dude, it's it's actually just wall-to-wall bad
points the whole time. It's not technically dark money. Omidyar
is one of the most transparent organizations to ever exist, and
so it's just not
dark
money. Omidyar is one of the most transparent organizations.
Like what he just said doesn't make sense there. Omidyar is a
last name. He's not referring to a particular group right there,
but to ever exist.
He's talking about Pierre Omidyar and the group of LLCs and and
charitable organizations that he runs. That Pierre Omidyar likes
transparency in these things. That he is overly transparent compared
to anybody else who does the same kind of giving, right? He's
He's way more transparent than them. Now, Destiny wants like
a level of transparency as in that that just doesn't exist,
And if there was a reason to demand that transparency, I would
understand it, but there isn't cuz there's no reason there's
no logical reason why he would lie about these things.
There's not >> So, it's just not >> That's okay.
>> It's just not a good argument to keep pushing on the
Omidyar slide in this >> I like that Substance only cut
the first part of Tom's stream though. >> And I had this
conversation with a number of content creators to stop pushing
the Omidyar thing because they also did not realize how wrong
this thing was, but they just kind of copied Destiny and repeated
the the [__] that he was saying.
Why would Why would Substance clip some other part of the stream?
What's the other part of the stream where Tom basically contradicts
himself?
These These points stand alone.
Why does he have to go clip some other part of the stream?
Can someone explain that to me? And try to do try to in good
faith. Why would he go and clip another part of the stream?
In like Unless the argument is Tom is a who's contradicting himself
between these two points. Is that what it is? Is Tom like a complete
who's contradicting himself? I'm not sure how you win arguments
by being really aggressively stupid. Well, huh, I'll be real,
this guy probably built himself up to like a 5 million plus dollar
net worth at some point based on that precise concept. So,
if it works, it works.
>> And so they don't think that Destiny is necessarily
actually >> I do wonder for a guy who used to be an 80's
Peter Nick Fuentes fan, how painful does like
Destiny going his Discord server's insides have to twist? >> Used
to be, dude.
Okay, all right.
The funny thing is is I could just go to like our DMs and show
the times where one I was like really upset that his community
was making this up about me. Uh I could go to the times where
I'm like sending him talking points for the Fuentes debate that
he was having.
I Like I could go to these things, but it doesn't matter. It's
like not a genuine position because realistically, while people
were saying these things about me, right? While they made these
things up about me, the the J Soc thing, that's totally fake.
It's totally made They denied it multiple times. Obviously had
a huge fight with Dan about it,
Totally made up. Um the fact that I was Nick Fuentes fan, I mean
secondary to being a Destiny fan and being like introduced to
Fuentes through his stream. Sure, I did watch. And then like
I said, I I checked out the foreign policy stuff cuz I was like
I was like the guy who's like, "I'm going to I'm going to explain
to people like how Nick Fuentes is wrong." And then for specifically
foreign policy, I'd look stuff up and I'm like, "Oh, this is
actually like pretty accurate. This is actually doing a pretty
good job of relaying these things. And I can point out where
the holes are in how he tells the story." But I I was like actually,
you know, I was like, "Oh, this guy actually did quite a bit
more work than I expected."
Doesn't mean I liked him. Doesn't mean I was a fan or supported
his positions. Just means I respected the work he put in and
the narratives he wove to basically tell his story.
Destiny talks about J Soc's Discord more than J Soc does, more
than really anybody does. This Discord lives in his mind. We
closed the channel, by the way, that talks about his lawsuit.
So I don't even know I don't even know why he's mad
What? Anyway. All right, I should back it up. So he's going to
make I think he's going to make a really stupid point here again.
Give me a second. >> And so I don't think that Destiny
is >> I do wonder for a guy who used to be an >> Nick
Fuentes fan, how painful does like J Soc and his Discord servers
insights have to twist to defend Taylor Lorenz and Hasan [__]
on every single point they say? >> Wait. Does he Is he
forgetting his position again?
That he believes Hasan [__] is like a a total anti-Semite,
a bigger anti-Semite than Myron Gaines? Did he forget that or
Wait. Does he he just he literally can't Can this guy not process
lying about two people at the same time? Does he not have like
the brain power, the bandwidth for it anymore? That like he suddenly
flips back, he's like, "Well, I'm lying about Jiker, so I I can't
lie about Hasan at this exact same time." Right? Right? I just
It's embarrassing to watch. Technically, if that were true, wouldn't
I want to agree with these people in your understanding of the
world or
By the way, my Discord all loves like Ethan Klein,
hates Hasan [__] hates Taylor Lorenz.
>> That's got to be a crazy
That's got to be a crazy mental world.
>> Yeah, this is really what it is, right? There's just
too many lies to keep straight. Like he's just consistently having
to lie about too many people. He can't keep them straight anymore.
He can't keep juggling all of the lies.
It's very goofy.
Alfakilo, it's it's not anything. It's a disam- It's It's not
anything.
It's literally a collection of consonants that are difficult
to pronounce to annoy people, so that everybody would say the
name differently and get annoyed.
That's That's what it was.
>> Uh she did she was just like The The other issue The
other issue here, too, is that like these guys are only anything
because I gave them the after hours like Destiny drama. So, to
see them try to like transition to talk about politics for real
is also very funny, but Could you ever
>> I guarantee you I have better political analysis on
this conflict than Destiny
Not even close.
Literally not even close. I'm sure American politics, like some
domestic issue, he could be better than me on that. I guarantee
you on this stuff, I'm way better than him.
Not even close. Also, fun fact, he told Darius on a live stream
once. Darius was like, he didn't Darius didn't understand why
he couldn't be the after hours And Destiny told him to his face
cuz he was sincerely asking, "Well, you can't talk about politics
and Jiker can, so." It's very funny
how that like flops It flip-flops all over the place, right?
You're closer to right about the 2024 election than he was. Well,
also, wasn't Destiny the guy that was all uh wasn't he the the
guy who's telling everybody the Republican Party's dead?
Like Trump Trump killed the Republican Party, it's all dead.
Guys, we don't have to worry about the Republicans anymore, that's
a dead party.
Many are his uh his political errors,
I just find it very funny. It's just very funny.
I don't know.
and trying to transition I want to do drama I wish there was
drama that I cared about, to be honest with you. But I've always
covered politics, too, so I don't I don't even know where this
comes
Which is weird, cuz he's been here while I cover politics. Very
goofy. >> Uh she she was just like The other The other
issue The other issue here, too, is that like these guys are
only anything because I gave them the after hours like Destiny
drama, so they >> These guys.
Sub since, didn't you know that he gave you the Destiny after
hours drama? Sub since, didn't you know that?
You're only anything cuz he gave you the Destiny after hours.
I Apparently, apparently, this also >> See them try to
like transition to talk about politics for real is also very
funny, but >> Did you ever get an answer out of her as
to why we never saw the damn contract?
>> Uh she she would just like vaguely allude to lawyers
or whatever, but that's yeah. >> She just vaguely allude
to lawyers or whatever. Well, actually, she said there was something
of a conflict there, was what she said specifically. Well, no,
actually, she said multiple things. Uh she said there were lawyers
initially, then she might have said something about a conflict,
but then her ultimate statement when I pushed and pushed and
pushed and pushed and pushed. Does anybody remember? The ultimate
statement After multiple hours of berating her in that conversation,
she said what? >> I'm pushing a was Well, I had a whole
bunch of quotes, but then I decided or my editors told me that
it looked bad, so I got rid of them all. That was her >> Oh,
didn't she she updated on this on Twitter, didn't she? I think
that's actually here
in one of these. Oh, the editor said it looked bad. I explained
it's a news article, and so it needs to be readable.
Having giant blocks of legalese is not readable. Myself any editor
with two brain cells would agree on that. I'm so grateful for
all these editors who edited my story to make it easy to understand.
Journalistic outlets, except in rare instances, do not ever publish
source material, especially in the case where it might be identifying.
I'm going to trust Condé Nast lawyers. They There are zero corrections
on our story.
Again, it's just like
Nobody here is disputing
the underlying
quotes about the contract.
Except creators who are saying who aren't actually disputing
the underlying quotes about the contract. It's like a stupid
word game where they don't say, "Well, the contract doesn't say
this." They say, "Well, I broke the contract and I don't I literally
I suffered no uh I suffered no consequences for it." Which is
different different.
Readability is good, but accuracy matters more. If simplifying
legal filings means changes the meaning, that's not edit just
editing for Everybody agrees with you, Spider. Yes, literally
everyone agrees with you, man.
Where Why do you believe that it's not
Would be the question, right? Why Why do we believe it's not
correct? Would be the question. It's pretty easy to understand
the
Final final final answer, okay? Now,
she said there was a conflict there as in she wasn't she wasn't
certain that if she leaked the contract that it wouldn't out
the person, that there wouldn't be some sort of special either
watermarks or phraseology or something about the the way the
contract set up, right? That gives away it sort of uniquely labels
it so that you could see who the person was. So, you can never
quote from any whatever. We're just supposed to believe
Why do you have to quote from it? I Again, it's not about believing,
it's about where's the dispute in what the contract says. In
any of anything about the the uh what do you call the references?
Any where would they describe the contract? What has been disputed
by Corus about the way the contract was described?
People from Corus have commented. No dispute.
Ryan Tyler Cohen did not dispute any of the characterizations
of the contract.
Nobody has disputed this.
Not even publicly.
Oh, the one person who did dispute one part of the contract was
that that girl with the glasses, and she was just wrong. She
was just wrong.
That was it.
There was a There was a creator. Yeah, some of the creators have
disputed it, but the the way they disputed it, okay? One of them
actually came out and said, "I disagree with your characterization
of the contract." And then she posted the contract section, and
she was just wrong. It just validated what was said in the article.
So, what's happening here is the way the contract is laid out,
they're not enforcing all provisions in the contract, right?
So, like there there's a reason they have There There seems to
be a reason that they have provisions in the contract that they
aren't interested in enforcing, certainly not strictly. And that's
like a conversation you could
right? But that conversation isn't being had. They're just saying
she's lying or or Wired, whoever, are lying about the contract.
But that doesn't seem to be the case.
If you want to say, "Well, they don't enforce the contract the
way it's And you want to have that conversation, that's a different
conversation. Totally valid conversation to have.
>> What about all the named content creators in the article?
Didn't they name literally like 10 content creators that agreed
to come forward and speak? None of those? >> What is the
problem with naming content creators who were speaking about
it? >> These guys could share their contract?
>> That's what she was concerned about, right? And so,
the funny thing is is I believe Destiny was actually asked later
to just publish the contract. What do you guys think he said?
>> I don't see that confidentiality thing in this unless
I'm misreading the under definitions or whatever. I don't know
if these contracts are like actually uniquely different per person,
so I don't want to risk like burning my contact on this, but
I see uh >> I don't want to risk BURNING MY CONTACT BECAUSE
I'M NOT WRITING A JOURNALISTIC STORY on it. I'm I literally got
one person ship me a >> I What does he not understand?
Cuz yeah, you're not writing a journalistic story, so I don't
have any reason to trust you, right? You're somebody who I know
to be like a liar. I don't trust you. Do we understand the purpose
of like a publisher in a case like this? That they have a reputation
to review materials that are too sensitive and then they could
say, well, we're going to review the materials. We're going to
put a note in the article that says we reviewed the materials
and this is what they say.
So, he goes, I'm like not I have no reputation at all. My reputation
is dog That's why I didn't want to publish it. Yeah, that's not
how it works, idiot.
Dude, what are we
Yeah, also yes, it's like oh, so if you're writing a journalistic
story, you should burn the person? I don't
I don't know.
If the journal lies, the magazine gets sued. It could easily
be sued. Yes. But nobody Apparently one creator did go and reach
out and say like this is incorrect or something and try to They
said they're going to file a lawsuit, I guess. Right? Isn't that
what Thomas is saying? One creator said they were going with
their lawyer to talk about it. Journalists get the most insane
insider information only because they obscure their source. Yes.
And Coden us probably doesn't have a good understanding of like
of how to protect the source and and still publish quotes. Like
that could easily be the case, right? That they just don't have
a good idea how to of how to do it. So, they say, well, we're
going to review it and then we'll just say what is said there.
And this does happen all the time.
And nobody has any problem with it.
Because again, if you're outright lying,
you will get in trouble.
You can be sued.
Now, I think they they kind of they try to make this argument.
Well, are are you are we just living in a world where you can
publish something and then it's on it's like only ever gets corrected
if somebody sues you? Like no.
But obviously not. Obviously like it's bad to publish things
without necessarily having any of the information there. But
in cases where that where the information should be protected
to protect the source, you don't have to publish it. And the
reason that these institutions exist for so long and become storied
is because they have a long track record of evaluating
correctly characterizing it, and publishing it. Right? That's
the whole purpose of this institution, of Condé Nast, of any
long-term publisher, is they can take information like this that
they're not sure if it's like okay to make it public. They can
evaluate that, and they can say, "Well, we're not going to, and
we're going to characterize it instead." You demand a retraction
and the publisher says no, that then you sue? Yeah, and I think
if if Corus went and said, "Here are the things you got wrong
about the contracts,"
what? They don't have to sue necessarily. Yeah, they could just
say, "Here, we're we're sending you an email. These are the things
you got wrong about the contracts.
Retract this." By the way, they could have commented at any point.
They didn't comment at any
Yeah, I I commented this on Twitter earlier, I think yesterday.
Just like, I guess the anti-vaxers were right. Like, um no, you
have to publish every single thing from your study or I don't
believe you. Literally publish all data from your study right
now or I don't believe you. Wait, but you can't even really evaluate
this Like, why would we do that? That's not required. Uh no,
no, no, unless you publish every single bit, every single piece
of data from all phases of your trial, I won't trust you. This
doesn't work. Vaccines are fake.
Vaccines are fake. Stop. Vaccines are >> want to risk like
burning my content on this, but I see um I don't want to risk
burning MY CONTENT BECAUSE I'M NOT WRITING A JOURNALISTIC STORY
ON IT. I'm I literally got one person sent me a The contract
was made in uh September.
But I'm not going to Why would I publish that to counter a story
that had doesn't have any proof or evidence for it? That doesn't
make any sense.
>> The proof and evidence is in the reputation, the 100-year
publisher who published the story.
That's the proof and evidence.
And all you have to do is admit,
right? All you have to do is move on at that point.
That's that's literally
that's all you have to do.
Is just go, "Well, listen, we can't really dispute that. We're
moving on." Sometimes I wonder what's happening inside of his
brain during one of these outbursts.
I think he's just angry. Yeah, I don't
I The The thing where he's like, "Oh, I can't believe this guy
who's anti-Semitic has to agree with these." It must hurt him
as an anti-Semite to agree with these people who have always
who have consistently labeled as anti-Semites like all the time.
I don't know what goes on in the brain there, either.
You know what I mean? I do think it's got to be some kind of
drug thing, no?
Like I I don't know precisely what it is, but there's something
like tangibly different at this point that's going on.
And I I can't explain it. Cuz I swear, I used to
I used to listen to this guy talk and it made sense.
And now it like never makes any sense.
Oh, so I don't under- I I do understand. I'm
Is the politics thing switching your brains on and off? The onus
is on the person making the claim, and it's so funny because
this is usually the case. If we're having a Twitch politics debate,
this is the case. If I make a claim, I have to back up that claim.
The way it works in journalism
is they can evaluate some information, decide they don't want
to publish that information or quotes from the the
and say, "We're going to explain that we looked at this, and
we're going to give our summary of what happened here, of what
was going on in this contract,
And if they want to dispute it, I'm sure Wired could could like
would be more than happy to take an email from Brian Tyler Cohen
from Corus and say, "Hey, you guys disagree with this story?
That's fine.
Go ahead and and send us like the contract that people got, and
if it's different than what we have, we'll we'll share with you,
and then we'll have a back and forth. We'll talk about it, right?"
I'm sure they'd be perfectly happy to talk about it. Newspapers
don't like to be wrong, by the way. I don't know if everybody
I don't know if anybody knows this. Newspapers really don't like
to be wrong at all.
They hate being wrong. They have a commitment to the truth.
Wired doesn't have Wired doesn't operate like Destiny, right?
What or like in in a case Listen, we have to make this understandable
for everybody. Wired doesn't operate like Hasan or Destiny, where
they're more concerned about being correct about being perceived
as correct than being actually correct, right? That's not how
journalists work. That's not how broadly most journalists work.
Most journalists are raised in a culture where pursuing truth
and and conveying that truth is their highest pursuit in
All of these major publishers that have existed for this long
are that's built into their bones. That's what they want to do.
So, when you when you try to explain this when you try to fight
with people on this, like
I I just don't understand why you try to make it about Taylor
Lorenz or about me. Attack Wired, right? Go after the strongest
portion. It's this stupid that Nicholas Ybarra does, too. You're
going to attack the person you perceive as weak and and so that
you can attack the reputation instead of having a substantive
argument.
Go after Wired. Go after Pierre Omidyar. When when Taylor says,
"Do you think Pierre Omidyar is defrauding people? Do you think
he is lying about this? Do you think he's being publicly deceptive
about this?" Go ahead and say you think he's lying.
Go ahead and say that, right?
Or straight-up attack Wired. He says to attack Wired, I think.
Oh, well, if he says that in this clip, yes, you do have to attack
Wired. Wired is the problem here, right? Go after Condé Nast.
Don't Don't attack Taylor, right? I think I I asked Food Shop
about this. Food Shop tweeted at me. Give me a second. I'll go
see if I can find it really quickly. I'm sure I'll find it here.
Oh, somebody is live tweeting my stream right now. I said asking
questions. I maybe can go through these. Give me a second. Should
be funny. The great sin is Taylor Lorenz not providing proof
in the original article, not that eventually somebody will come
and leak the contract and confirm whether or not she's correct
or not. No, this isn't the thing.
This isn't the thing at all. Also
not getting a lot of traction on her tweet that is particularly
stupid. Fantastic. You love to see it. Taylor is not alone in
making the claim. Wired is also making the claim. The publishing
parent company has been a publisher for over century uh centuries
Condé Nast. They're putting their institutional weight behind
the claim. Why is this a problem in this case? Right? Why isn't
this a problem in any of the other cases about Trump and other
people where they quote a source like a source who wants to remain
anonymous,
If you have a source that wants to remain anonymous and they
only know the thing because of their position in life, isn't
that a huge problem? Don't you just You objectively can't prove
anything in that article. Every single Every single article based
on anonymous sourcing is gone by this definition. It's fundamentally
It's so stupid, man.
This is the dumbest argument I've ever
And people are buying it because it's Destiny making it. Guess
what? Your goat fell off. I don't know how to tell you guys this,
okay? Find somebody else. Your goat fell off. This is a terrible
It's just objectively bad. Don't make it. You look stupid.
Have some shame.
And so food drops falls on Wired is clearly a factual media platform.
But Taylor Lorenz is one of these bad people existing in that
sphere that makes these
>> Don't be
What? This is unironically in this moment, it's like Wired is
a media platform, but Taylor Lorenz has a really bad reputation.
It's like, okay, but Wired is making the claim. The The screenshot
here. According to copies of the contract viewed by Wired that
creators signed, the influencers are not allowed to disclose
the relationship with Chorus or the 1630 fund or functionally
that they're being paid at all, right? Yo, weaselly little liar
dude, thank you for the gifted sub to crap merchant, appreciate
it. Thank you, thank you, thank you.
did I even finish this? Wired is it a clearly a factual media
platform, but Taylor Lorenz is one of these bad people existing
within that sphere that makes these claims. I don't see how Wired
corroborating her article has anything to do with Taylor herself
providing evidence to the viewer themselves.
You don't need the whole reason they corroborate is because they
feel they can't give the evidence,
This is again, just think of the unnamed source, a an anonymous
source close to the situation,
right? How do we think all of those articles work?
How do we think the the profile that came out from the New York
Times explaining the lead-up to the war in Iran? How do we think
that story worked? Anonymous sourcing, according to people familiar
with the matter, according to people who were in the room, according
to people who wish to remain anonymous, who are attached to the
situation. And you trust the reputation of the writer of the
article because if they are found to be lying, their reputation
is
right? That's the whole point.
So, I I provide this follow-up. You trust party A, but not party
B. Party A makes a statement that is included in an article by
party B. Explain to me why party B being untrustworthy invalidates
the statement.
So, we have a statement from Wired, right? Like this is this
is invoking Wired directly saying Wired clears this, Wired agrees
with this.
So, I guess you could argue that Wired editors didn't catch that
Taylor was writing this article in a way where she was referencing
Wired like being behind her, but that doesn't make any sense,
Maybe maybe that that could be your argument, I don't know. I
don't I don't know. So, again, why is this statement invalid?
Like imagine Taylor when when this statement is made, right?
Remove Taylor Lorenz from the equation. Why do you disagree with
this? Why are you saying that a journalist that a journalistic
that a publisher can't make a claim without providing all source
Or even quotes. I It doesn't matter if we say quotes, right?
I don't have to be hyperbolic there and say all source materials.
Quotes.
Why do you need them to provide quotes? Why is that required?
You don't like the story. That's fine. I understand you don't
like the story.
By the way, there's ways you can defend
despite the story.
Why don't you just go that route? Why don't you just do the obvious
defenses?
My main problem with this has been how people have reacted. To
be honest, if Chorus had just commented, I think they they take
this wind out of all of this.
They just refuse to comment.
Very sad. Very very sad. Okay. Anyway, uh no response to this,
by the
Yeah, no response at all. Yeah. Just no response. Sad. Sad. Sad.
>> I think Ethan
I think Ethan Klein talked about Hassan doing this or somebody
else doing this. The idea that you publish a story with a whole
bunch of lies in it, and then you expect the other person to
leak a whole bunch of server published with this stuff to try
to discredit lies, even though they never proved the lies in
the first place.
>> The same reason he doesn't want to publish the full
thing for the same
>> Listen to these guys like stumbling their way through
politics trying to figure [__] out is painful.
Watching Destiny's stream where he tried to research after losing
two debates, he tried to research the topic. That was
I think I'm quite elegant when I talk about politics, to be honest.
Okay, this guy is tweeting at me. Going to do one-time special
service,
At 1 hour 18 45, you ask why substance should include later segments
in Tom's stream. Destiny is claiming that because he is trying
to frame the criticism as team siding. The fact that Tom later
calls Loren a liar means that Tom is still on Destiny's team.
If Destiny is wrong on a point, he often engages Oh, I thought
this guy was like trying to This guy is giving me analysis. I
thought this guy was calling me out. This guy's just giving me
analysis. Bro, I'm not looking for a co-host. But thank you.
Thank you for Listen, thank you for engaging under the blast
off tweet unlike a bunch of losers in this chat. Okay? Look,
this guy is doing more to help the stream than a ton of people
in this chat right now who have not registered Twitter accounts,
who have not gone and retweeted the stream or liked the stream.
Okay? This guy is doing more. If Destiny is wrong on a point,
he often engages in tactical nihilism to blow up an argument
so he never has to take that L. That's why in this case Destiny
frames substance as a clip chimper who isn't on Destiny's team
and is just nitpicking Destiny on a small point. Wow. Okay. Yeah.
Oh, I still haven't done the Kilo tweet. That's the The substantial
thing here is the Kilo tweet. Kilo actually went out of his way
to write do like a big write-up on this, right? And I do think
he hits the nail on the head in that the almost the entire conversation
sort of just a red herring from the actual problem, which is
transparency.
Like that's all people want is transparency. That it's hit on
again and again in the article. It's hit on again and again by
everybody who cares about this at all. It's about transparency.
People shouldn't be giving massive amounts of money without identifying
themselves. People shouldn't be accepting massive amounts of
money or even regular amounts of money. A substantial portion
of your wage shouldn't be accepted with zero
That's it. Okay? So let's let's uh check this out. This is in
response to some Destiny post.
Hey Taylor Lorenz, we we covered this last night. She He's bringing
up the Omidyar Network thing. So I It turns out it seems like
this is actually a refund from Pierre donating. So I think Pierre
gave that $45 million and I think they refunded to his LLC. I
think this is a refund from some program he was supposed to be
supporting.
I think that's all this is.
Or at least that's what I read. I I haven't gone and validated
that deeply, but I That's what I read and that makes sense. I
thought maybe it was um like him getting them for one of his
projects to to contract his own lawyers and [__]
Okay, anyway, dark money isn't any entity that could theoretically
hide funds ever because that describes literally every LLC, private
C corp, S corp, family trust, family office, partnership, holding
company, or even many public companies with subsidiaries. By
this logic, almost every corporation on earth is dark money.
Actual dark money, anonymous donors we know are hidden, no disclosure
required or given, non-partisan political purpose, ads, influence
ops, rapid response messaging.
I think there's a little bit more to talk about there than just
these two
I do think these this is like a good start. So, I'll just run
with it cuz I'm like Yivo Cook. The 1635 checks both of the above
boxes. The reporters and residents program checks neither. Right?
So, on and it not only that,
the transparency for the reporters and residents thing, Taylor
herself disclosed, the company publicly dis- disclosed, and the
company says this is funded by Pierre Omidyar. Pierre Omidyar
has had like been wanting to fund basically people who do transparent
journalism and and journalism around transparency specifically.
Yes, they are Glenn Greenwald types. He funded the people I think
he got caught in the Panama Papers or the Paradise Papers, okay?
I think he literally got caught
farming [__] out like I I like basically using some
sort of offshore bank accounts. And you know what he did?
He funded those people.
I think I think his money was going through and getting like
offshored and cleaned for him, so he wasn't paying taxes. And
you know what his response was? Here's more money to keep doing
this kind of journalism. Okay? That was the response.
that's awesome. Come on, you got to give it up that that's awesome.
That feels that feels cool, right? Okay, anyway. It's funded
by one named billionaire, Pierre and Pam Omidyar, supports non-partisan
journalism, the journalists maintain full editorial independence,
and the purpose of their corporate structure is not to obscure
donors. Yes. So, like they're literally saying, "We are the donors."
Could they be lying? Could they be lying in that case? Possibly,
but they've put their reputation on this. They're saying the
entire purpose of like the dark money thing is that you're not
attached. You you have no consequence. Pierre Omidyar has takes
on the consequences. He's somebody with with a reputation. He's
somebody with a money who is taking on the consequences of the
money that he has and is donating,
That's what you're looking for. Who are you holding responsible
for something if it's donated to? Well, it's Pierre Omidyar,
right? If he has other people there, he is still being held responsible.
He is like the big name with all of the money in the trust. It's
I do believe it's not even really dis- it's not disputed by anyone.
This is what he does with his money, right?
So, it's it's just goofy that we're like pretending there's something
else going on here. And again, we will just ask give me a plausible
situation, give me a plausible explanation for why this wouldn't
be the case
in order to continue the conversation. Okay. The screenshot Destiny
shared shows the 1630 Fund gave $45,000 to an Omidyar Network
LLC arm, the Network Services arm, in 2022 for civil rights social
action advocacy. Uses this screenshot to suggest that she could
potentially be funded by dark money or is. He absolutely suggests
that, yes. The problem is that the Reporters in Residence program
didn't even exist yet. It was founded in 2023. Taylor didn't
join until 2025.
Journalist gets $50,000 over 6 months, and the classes for the
fellowships are multiple people. So, one $45,000 grant from 2022
cannot possibly be the source of her funding 3 years later. Lol.
It's a drop in the bucket compared to what their actual source
likely is, primarily just Omidyar.
Omidyar's official statement still up. Omidyar Network receives
no funding for the Reporters in Residence program via the 1630
Fund or any other outside sources. And even if you stretch it,
this is a red herring. Lorenz's article wasn't any dark money
ever equals bad. It was about the tandem of hidden anonymous
political money and gag contracts and zero transparency to creators
/ public. Her fellowship has none of that and has nothing to
do with anything. This entire but you get dark money too, while
being factually untrue, is also just a gigantic red herring that
completely sidesteps the core point being made in the article,
which is about
Maybe for the rest of time we should just pretend Taylor Lorenz
does take dark money if it would force people to actually engage
with the substance of what she wrote about. Like yeah, I actually
she's a total hypocrite. Did you engage with the article? Yeah.
She's a total hypocrite, she takes dark money, whatever, I don't
care. Engage with the article. Do you not agree that these contracts
would be
Thank you. Yeah.
Love this Kilo guy. He does good stuff. Does good work, okay?
Now if he could just finish his
Finish the
Finish the video, Kilo.
Just finish the How hard is it to finish the video, man? How
hard is it? Just finish the video.
We're waiting. We're waiting. We're waiting.
All right.